so
i'm curious i always like to ask this to
uh every director i speak with
if you could get the financing for
anything that you want to make tomorrow
what would you make and why whoa that's
that's big uh
yeah i like to start off with you know
the fastball
uh man i've always wanted to make a
movie
like underwater uh you know like some
sort of underwater
research something you know like
a station or something like that you
know where people are having to
move around in little pods uh that would
be
so i don't know what the movie is but
that's the the general idea
and also it's a good excuse to call
james cameron and be like hey
i need to say underwater stuff jimmy uh
sorry i haven't answered your your texts
uh i've been a little busy
right um one of the things i really
enjoyed about this film
is that it doesn't have a villain it's
about people
dealing with a bad situation uh can you
sort of talk about that aspect of this
yeah you know that's part of the little
trilogy that um my co-writer and i
worked on
um the first one was that we wrote was
this stowaway and the second one was
arctic
which was initially set on mars so that
was part of
more of a trilogy and then the third one
was called grounded uh which was people
trying to get to mars but
there's stuff getting in the way um so
yeah you know
for those three films we wanted the same
kind of idea the
the fact that there isn't a
machiavellian
mustache twirling villain uh there isn't
any kind of
of bad guy is just a bad situation
in my life i haven't had an antagonist
i've only had
i've had a lot of troubles but they have
all been
the environment you know sometimes
literally when i've been trying to shoot
a film in 19 days in iceland
you know so uh yeah you know that's what
i connected with the most and that's
what
my co-writer connected with the most and
that's where we decided to take these
three films
i'm always curious about the editing
process because it's the final rewrite
uh did the film change at all in the
editing room did you have a much longer
cut
well my co-writer is actually my editor
which
you know scares a lot of producers
because they're like no you need
somebody who
is in a whole somewhere who doesn't know
anything about production
anything about the script just give them
the footage and then they'll come up
with something
incredible um but you know the the
approach that we have always taken at
you know with youtube and
with the short films and when you're
just like trying to get it done
you have to be very very very
okay with just cutting things you know
like oh we spent like two days shooting
this one scene
get rid of it no big deal um so when
that's the approach
uh then you can do it on set so
literally with arctic we needed
him on set because on set there wasn't a
set for that
but you know in in the snow because
you know you you don't have time to do
reshoots you're not going to get mad
it's
going to regrow his beard and you're not
going to like
you know wait one year until you have
the snow again to reshoot something
um so yeah you know it
it was something where it was kind of
like laying there the tracks in front of
us
as we went along uh we still think we
had a little bit more time
um so we were he was there on set
the whole time too he had his own little
office sometimes right next
to where we were shooting and that was
nice because we saw
it coming together sometimes i could
show the actors
something to be like this is how the
scene ended up
let's shoot what comes after that and
sometimes
you're watching the edit and you're
saying oh you know what this
interaction between anna kendrick and
daniel the game is working so well let's
write
another scene with the two of them um so
we did
you know we there was one day where we
had a little bit of extra time
we wrote an extra scene handed it to the
actors they memorized it right there on
the spot and
we shot it and it's one of the better
scenes in the film
in my opinion do you think they made it
to mars
um and how did you decide where to end
the film
where to end my films is always the
biggest question
there's always a month-long discussion
about which
frame exactly especially with arctic
uh you know uh we're we're going to to
cut on
uh so so with this one you know
especially the voiceover at the end
um and everything that happens right
then and there
that was such a difficult thing to write
and that was something that we wrote
after everything was done
and that we knew we wanted right after
everything was done because we wanted to
watch the film
until that final little voice over
because we wanted it to be
as hopeful as that bleak ass ending
is or can be you know uh
you know we wanted to be as hopeful as
possible um
and yeah i wanted to to
be open uh you know some people if
you're more of a pessimist
uh you you're probably gonna see it as
like okay well they never make it to
virus and some people who are
more of the optimists uh they'll
probably see it as uh oh yeah yeah no
they'll figure out a way to fix anna
by the end of it got it i have to go
congrats on the movie i hope you're
making something again soon
thank you very much